hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Sean Carroll we're here
for idea number 17 which is matter by
matter I mean not what matters in life
but the matter that you and I are made
of the ground beneath our feet the
planets the Sun the stars things like
that the stuff out of which we are made
and I'll admit that this represents a
shift in the biggest ideas series for a
couple of reasons you know we're not
gonna have an infinite number of biggest
ideas videos sorry there's a finite
number I had a plan when I started the
plan has shifted a little bit as we've
gone on but there is an ending point in
sight we were closer to the end than we
are to the beginning sorry about that so
we're gonna be finishing up with a
slightly different kind of ideas we've
done a lot of work recently on building
up quantum field theory and the standard
model engage theories and things like
that and we have other fish to fry as it
were so we're gonna be less about that
this video will still be about quantum
field theory but it'll be about a more
tangible aspect of quantum field theory
so the focus and the biggest ideas will
always be conceptual it will always be
the big underlying ideas not the
nitty-gritty of this and act but now
we're gonna get into things that are a
little bit more relevant a little bit
more not relevant familiar let us put it
that way
easily grasped to us so even in this
video on matter so what I should say is
having said that even though this video
is about matter you might think well
okay it's gonna be about materials and
things like that and you know it's it's
really not because I don't know anything
about that stuff you should go to other
people who know more about that for
those topics I want to connect some of
the conversation we've been having about
quantum field theory and the underlying
laws of physics to the features of
matter that we that make up you and me
okay in particular most of today's idea
is going to be on a single feature of
matter which is that it can be solid
right that a table is solid you can't
just put your hands on it and fall right
through this might not seem like a
question but we'll ask it anyway
you know why is matter solid
you might remember back way back in one
of the early videos we were talking
about the fact that just before quantum
mechanics came on the scene you could
have imagined
in the late 1800s you could have
imagined a version of physics where
there were two different kinds of stuff
there were particles that made up matter
you know the particles that we would now
know is the electron the proton the
neutron and so forth and there were
forces that pushed and pulled the matter
together that's not exactly right but
there's a very close relative to that
and so today we're gonna explore the
matter side when we talked about gauge
theories the other day we're really
talking about the forces side of things
so why is matter solid at all now you
might think well once you know about
atoms and particles this shouldn't be
difficult question you know if you have
some collection of atoms you can just
stack them on top of each other or maybe
you could be supposed to be atoms not
just bowling balls why can't you just
stack things on or of course atoms can
stick to each other right with chemical
bonds and you would imagine there is
some solidity there that that makes
sense but then you remember we're
drawing atoms as little spheres we know
better right atoms are not little
spheres atoms are quantum objects in
particular the size of the atom as we
talked about in the video on scale is
set by the Compton wavelength of the
electron it's really set by the Bohr
radius which is the Compton wavelength
divided by the fine-structure constant
so the electron has a wave function
right the electron wave function is wavy
it's sort of smooth and you could easily
imagine deforming it so the question is
why can't why aren't they squishy
why aren't atoms squishy this is one
question by which I mean that looks like
squash II let me make it look more like
squishy by which I mean you could easily
imagine didn't look like squash II it
was like squishy if I have two atoms
like this one right on top of each other
and I push them on the bottom and on the
top why don't they just squeeze down to
more elliptical shapes so that they're
much
smaller okay well well they're much
smaller in one direction maybe wider in
some other direction why don't they just
deform they're just waves after all and
the answer is sort of implicit in what
we talked about when we were talking
about wave functions and the shape of
atoms in the first place namely that the
electron in a hydrogen atom or even more
complicated atom its wavefunction has
the shape it does because it's trying to
minimize its energy right is trying to
minimize its energy subject to certain
constraints may be there are other
electrons in the way it's being
attracted by the nucleus and so forth so
if you you can certain you can imagine
taking an atom and squishing it there's
no problem with imagining doing that but
its energy would change and since its
energy is already at the minimum given
the constraints it's subject to the
energy has to go up you have to put
energy into it you might imagine that's
not much energy right like how much
energy can it take you might be a
squishy kind of springy thing but in
fact it's a lot of energy if you changed
you know in a table if you changed all
the electrons energies by one percent
that turns out to be an enormous amount
of energy I didn't actually calculate it
that's a good homework problem I predict
it would be something like an atomic
bombs worth of energy if you wanted to
squish all the atoms in a table to
change their electrons energy by one
percent so there's a reason why
electrons want to remain spherical in
atoms it's because they're in their
lowest energy states already it would
take a lot of energy to change them but
there's another question why don't they
fall on top of each other why don't
atoms go on top of each other why are
they solid individually so we say the
tables are solid because they're made of
little atoms right so that presumes that
the atoms themselves have some ability
to take up space right to occupy volume
so why can't we just imagine going from
two atoms pushing them together and then
this goes into one atom right on top of
another one right what's what's the
danger of that it's not quantum
mechanics per se that is the problem
there there's no problem with having two
electron
overlapping in their wave functions I
mean electrons in an atom do that but
they don't do it arbitrarily there are
rules that they follow and that's
basically what we're going to be talking
about today in today's video to give
away the secret which I like to do we're
gonna be talking talking about the
properties of fermions fermions are a
certain kind of particle named after
Rico Fermi famous italian-american
physicist and they are in Contra
distinction to bosons and roughly
speaking bosons named after professor
Bose whose first name I can't pronounce
who's an Indian professor so Bose hooked
up with Einstein to invent Bose Einstein
statistics which are particles of a
certain kind roughly speaking particles
that like to pile on top of each other
particles that actually prefer to be in
the same place if you have identical
particles of the same species or bosons
fermions obey what are called Fermi
Dirac statistics after Fermi and drak
and they'd like to take up space from
yawns do not like to be on top of each
other so the glib answer to why atoms
don't want to be on top of each other is
because electrons which are giving you
the size of the atoms are fermions they
take up space they don't want to be on
top of each other but we want to get
closer to why that's actually true
okay so the name of this principle that
says why not is the pout that that says
that this doesn't happen rather is the
Pauli exclusion principle so again this
is a the fact the the motto electrons
take up space is a very cute little
retelling of the Pauli exclusion
principle which is a precise
quantitative statement which says that
two electrons cannot be in exactly the
same quantum state at the same time now
even though exclusion principle is is
less than there is to the story there's
more to it than that but this is a nice
simple way of thinking about what's
going on if you imagine the shape of an
electron wave function in an atom if you
tried to put two electrons in exactly
the same state which works out to be
both the same the same shape for their
wave function and also the same spin you
can't do that according to the pal the
exclusion principle so that is what we
want to get to two fermions
cannot occupy the same state quantum
state of course it's a quantum state
what else would it be
well you want to talk a little bit about
why that's true and also to give away
some of the surprise at the end you may
have heard fermions defined as particles
that have a spin of one half or three
halves or five halves half-integer spin
as we call so bosons have spins of zero
one two integer spins that's true but
that's not the definition there's a
separate fact about fermions which is
that they have a spin of one-half
three-halves etc but the defining
principle of them is this they do not
take up the same quantum state the
connection between the taking up space
and the having half integer spin is
called the spin statistics theorem and
we'll talk a little bit about that in a
somewhat unsatisfying way okay so what
is a fermion that's what we got to get
into here and fermions well we could
just list all the ones we know what is a
firm young they are either quarks the
ones we know are either quarks so that's
up down charm strange top bottom or what
we call the leptons which are the
electron the muon the Tau the muon and
the Tau or just heavier cousins of the
electron they're the same in every other
way except for their mass and then there
are the neutrinos and there's sort of
one neutrino for each charged leptons is
an electron neutrino a muon neutrino and
a Tau neutrino these are all the
fermions that we know about let me think
I hope not skipping any it's always hard
to actually remember when you're a
working physicist because there's so
many hypothetical fermions that we
almost take for granted they exist but
these are the ones we actually know
these are the fermions of the standard
model of particle physics and what makes
them fermions okay consider two
particles so we're gonna consider the
quantum mechanical wave function for two
particles
and part of the whole discourse we're
gonna have through this video is that
we're going to remember that deep down
we're talking about quantum field theory
okay but we're not going to really do
any quantum field theory so we're gonna
work with particles as if their original
official particles all by themselves but
we remember in the back of our minds
that what these particles are are a
certain way of talking about quantum
fields in what we call low energy states
right the lowest energy state is zero
particles the slightly higher energy
state is one particle and there are
states with two particles three
particles etc so we're talking about
particles but they come from quantum
fields and that will actually matter so
what is the wavefunction for two
particles look like and forget about
spin and things like that we're not
gonna go into those quite yet we'll get
there eventually so the wave function
capital sci for two particles just
depends on where they are particle one
is that x1 and particle two is that x2
let's say for example okay there you go
we're not to say what it is yet but
we're gonna drive some properties of the
wave function for two quantum particles
and in fact let's imagine these are
identical particles oops
identical why would we imagine that well
um they don't have to be there are
particles that are not identical a
proton and electron are not identical
but two electrons are identical
particles now why are there identical
particles we're gonna refer back to the
fact that they come from quantum field
theory two electrons in two different
places are two different vibrations in
the same underlying field so of course
they are identical they're their
particle Ness is not what makes up
nature field this is what makes up
nature and it's the same feel that is
giving rise to these two electrons the
same exact properties of the field so of
course the particles that we get by
looking at I braised in electron field
will be identical particles so that is
something that we inherit from the fact
that it's really quantum fields going on
and now we want to ask well what happens
if we exchange the two particles with
each other the thing to remember here is
that x1 and x2 are not
cific locations in space right there
what we call the argument of the
wavefunction so there are two different
labels on our three-dimensional space
one of which says what is the likelihood
of finding particle one there and the
other one says particle two so you see
that already something interesting is
going on if the particles are identical
I mean how do you know which one you've
seen if you actually measured have you
seen particle one or particle two so
there's probably some relationship that
relates x1 and x2 to each other in the
wavefunction or rather what we could say
is there's got to be some feature of
this function sy that relates x1 and x2
to each other because we don't know when
we measured a particle which one it is
we're actually measuring because they're
just vibrations in the field so a way to
think about this is to imagine
interchanging what if we what if we
exchanged the two particles so let's
send sy of X 1 comma X 2 to something
which we're going to call the
interchange operator so you know this is
something that takes the wavefunction
and switches the two particles so the
interchange operator acting on Phi of X
1 and X 2 which guess what is going to
be equal to sigh of X 2 comma X 1 as a
function so again mathematicians are
gonna be a little bit annoyed by this
notation but you know what I mean it's
the hope okay and we want to figure out
what this actually means what this what
properties they should have so there are
two things we know about this just on
the basis of quantum mechanics okay one
thing that we know is that if you
interchange the two particles and then
you interchange them again you get back
where you started
okay nothing actually happened so one
thing is that the interchange operator
the act of switching the two particles
if that were to act on what you get by
acting on the interchange operator if
this reminds you of our group Theory
discussion that's probably not a
coincidence this is a set of
transformations you can do on this wave
function then you act that on
sigh of X 1 comma X 2 you better get
back where you started so that is sigh
of X 1 comma X 2 you didn't do anything
you switched them and you switch them
back that seems kind of obvious and not
worth noting but believe me we're gonna
have to note it the other thing that we
know is that if you only interchange
once so if you just do the interchange
on sigh X 1 and X 2 because they are the
same because they are identical
particles because they are vibrations in
the same underlying quantum field there
can't be any observable consequence of
doing this ok and this is where quantum
mechanics comes in because quantum
mechanics distinguishes between what is
real and what you can observe you can't
observe the wavefunction directly right
what can you observe you can actually
measure to see is the particle at X 1 or
X 2 so basically what you can measure is
the probability of measuring particles
there when you look that's when you can
calculate that's what you care about
that's the quantity that gives you
observable predictions is the
probability so this better equal the
same physical situation because they're
identical particles interchanging the
two shouldn't change the physical
situation and what that means is that
the probability of observing a particle
of X 1 and X 2 is of course capital psy
of X 1 comma X 2 magnitude squared so
this thing therefore psy squared doesn't
change let's let let me let me write it
in a little bit more formal way of
saying it size squared equals whatever
you get by interchanging sigh and then
squaring that this is the requirement
that the physical situation the
predictions the observable outcome does
not change if you interchange two
identical particles with each other
so then you have two possibilities there
are two ways to satisfy these two things
we know one is if you do interchanging
twice nothing happens
what the other is of you interchanging
only once you better make the same
physical predictions so there's two
possible two ways to satisfy these two
criteria one is the obvious way okay if
you interchange I was going to write int
know along rather than the whole word
interchange if you interchange Sai x1
and x2 maybe you just get back Sai x1 x2
maybe nothing happens to it at all okay
this would be the intuitive non quantum
mechanical thing if you had two
identical particles and you switch them
for each other and you know so you did
someone did that while you weren't
looking
you wouldn't know right it looks exactly
the same maybe it looks exactly the same
because it is exactly the same that is
absolutely a possibility and this
possibility is realized in quantum
mechanics and recall particles that obey
this relation bosons
that's what bosons are bosons are
particles for which when you have two
identical ones if you switch them in the
wave function the wave function doesn't
change at all so just to make that clear
for example eg for some size of one
particle okay so imagine now someone
gives you a wave function of just a
single particle I can instantly create a
wave function for two boson ik particles
that satisfies these criteria right I
can let capital sigh of x1 x2 be just
sigh of x1 times 5x - this is a
perfectly good boson equate function
note that if this first wave function
were different than that one then in
general this would not be a good wave
function for a boson ik particle because
if I switch them it would not get the
same answer so more generally for two
different functions
little side one and little side two I
can make a boson equate function capital
sign by taking side 1 of X 1 site 2 of X
2 but then adding plus psy 2 of X 1 psy
1 of X 2 ok and these are just numbers
so I want X 2 their numbers for every
value of X 1 and X 2 so they commute and
everything like that there's nothing
funny business going on but by
construction by the way that we made
this particular wave function it will
always be the case that we've satisfied
these two criteria you interchange twice
and you don't change anything you're
gonna change once and you make the same
probability exactly because in fact you
just get the same exact wave function we
interchange that's automatic no matter
what the specific function side one side
two here are so bosons are allowed
physical particles and the bosons of the
standard model are photons and gluons
and W and Z bosons and the Higgs boson
and the graviton there you go graviton
you can debate whether accounts but
accounts so what this means is that
there is no objection to two different
identical bosons having the same exact
quantum state and in fact what Bose
showed is that they'd like to have the
same quantum state given one boson just
sitting there in some quantum state
another one actually likes to cuddle up
with it you know they like to be
sociable they like to be right on top of
each other doing exactly the same thing
that's what bosons like to do so bosons
can pile on to each other and therefore
this has a very very important dramatic
effect in macroscopic world physics they
can give rise to long range macroscopic
forces okay the reason why you could
discover the gravitational field or the
electromagnetic field as big classical
fields long before you had discovered
gravitons or photons is because
gravitons and photons are bosons and
they can pile on top of each other to
give you a strong detectable field
in the classical regime so they can give
rise they don't always necessarily but
they can give rise to macroscopic
classical fields gravity and
electromagnetism are mediated by bosons
now the strong force is also mediated by
bosons gluons are very happy to pile on
but because of confinement they don't
ever escape the proton of the neutron so
we don't see them the weak force W and Z
bosons also happy to pile on just like
the Higgs boson also happy to pile on
but those particles are so massive they
just decay away very quickly so the
massless non confined bosonic fields can
give rise to long-range macroscopic
force fields and guess what that's
exactly what they do you shouldn't be
surprised okay there's another way to
satisfy these two criteria here are the
criteria interchange once and you get
the same probability but not necessarily
the same state and change twice and you
get the same quantum state well you're
gonna guess what it is you're gonna
guess correctly the other way to satisfy
it is that interchanging sigh of x1 x2
gets you - sigh of x1 x2 if you only
knew this second criterion that you
interchange once and you get the same
probability then you would say well ok
any complex phase e to the I theta could
multiply the wavefunction when I
exchange two particles but you really
want the wavefunction to be exactly
unchanged when you do it twice so it
really needs to be multiplying by minus
one is the only possibility by the way
footnote here nothing that we say in
this video is rigorous sometimes I'm
able to take a rigorous argument and
give you a version of it that is
understandable and transferable and make
sense this whole subject is one in which
there are rigorous arguments but they're
just difficult they're just
intrinsically difficult even to say in
words so I'm offering plausibility
arguments more than anything else so
sticklers will know that you know
whether or not bosons and fermions are
the only kinds of fields depends on the
number of dimensions of space-time for
each
which you know not mentioning here but
if you if space-time we're
three-dimensional set of
four-dimensional you'd be telling a very
different story but we're we're just
taking the shortcuts here to give you
what we want you to understand why this
makes sense
not necessarily to rigorously know that
it's been proven true okay those are our
standards so this this is another way
that you can satisfy the criteria that
we settled and this way is called
fermions this is what fermions do
fermions are particles for which in a
multi particle wave function when you
exchange two of them the wave function
picks up a minus sign that's the real
definition of what fermions are okay so
that means they can't be in the same
state so for example you could make a
fermionic state sigh X 1 of X 2 and X 2
which is equal to some function psy 1 of
X 1 times some other function side 2 of
X 2 minus sy 2 of X 1 Phi 1 of X 2 okay
so now you notice just by this version
of this formulation of how I wrote the
wave function that if I let X 1 go to X
2 the wave function as a whole picks up
a minus sign that's what fermions are
supposed to do and then you also notice
that if sy 1 equals sy to as functions
then this capital sy would have to equal
0 you can't make a wave function by
multiplying to one particle wave
functions together and then antisymmetry
Singh in this way if the two wave
functions are identical unless the whole
thing is just exactly 0 so this is the
way that we have to derive the fact that
fermions that this is it gives us the
poly exclusion principle let me just say
it that way this says that two particles
cannot be in the same state
Palli exclusion principle probably by
the way is just one of the heroes of
early quantum mechanics he didn't quite
get there to invent matrix mechanics or
the Schrodinger equation but he mends a
lot of stuff he was also like really
difficult to get along with you know he
was very notorious for telling other
people how stupid they were sometimes
the other people were actually
rekt and then he would go on and develop
their ideas and get credit for them so
like there was Polly's students I think
who first suggested the idea of spin and
he said that they were idiots and they
shouldn't do that and someone else show
that spin was really there and probably
developed the whole spin matrices and
everything about spin that we now know
and love today so he was smart but you
know even smart people are not always
right
anyway the exclusion principle very very
important so this is anti symmetry right
this is an anti symmetric wave function
it implies that side one cannot equal
side two but they can be different so
you can have two fermions in two
different states and then the total wave
function would look like this and if you
want to say oh that that looks like
they're entangled with each other yeah
that's exactly right you know two
identical particles have to be entangled
in this way two fermions have to be
entangled in this way to bosons can just
be right on top of each other in exactly
the same state which would not be
entangled but fermions always got to be
entangled okay
okay so this means in other words that
fermions take up space that's what we've
learned because they cannot be two
fermions cannot have exactly the same
wavefunction one way or the other and
that is why atoms are solid because you
know this is again simplification
because there's something like spin that
we're gonna talk about in a second but
roughly speaking if you imagine two
hydrogen atoms okay two protons with a
single electron around them and you try
to put them right on top of each other
those two electrons would want to be in
the same quantum state but the Pelley
solution principle says they can't okay
it's a better example of helium atoms
but you know we've done hydrogen more
than helium so let's just talk about
that okay so this is usually called so
bosons versus fermions that that
classification that classification is
known as the statistics of the particles
they this distinction first became
noticeable or noticed when people Bose
and Einstein bear me and Dirac we're
actually thinking about large
collections of
many particles and then the fact that
the particles either want to take up
space or pile on top of each other
clearly effects the statistical
likelihood that they're going to be in
different quantum mechanical States
okay so Bose Fermi statistics the word
statistics is what is used to say
whether or not a particles of boson or a
fermion does it obey Bose statistics or
does it obey fair mean statistics and
bosons is a little bit redundant but I'm
saying it anyway just to stick in bosons
give rise to forces fermions give rise
to matter now what we said was that to
obey our two rules for what happens when
you interchange two particles there were
two options either be boson or fermionic
there's no in between there's no rule
that says that a theory needs to have
both but of course the standard model
particle physics certainly does
supersymmetry is a hypothetical symmetry
that tries to relate bosons to fermions
it says there is a symmetry
transformation in nature that Maps a
boson ik field to a fermionic field and
vice versa the standard model is clearly
not super symmetric there is no mapping
of the fermion fields on to the boson
fields that that satisfies any symmetry
but you could imagine that like the
electroweak symmetry supersymmetry is
broken spontaneously and so for every
Fermi on there is a partner which is a
boson and vice-versa but they're just
too heavy because remember symmetry
breaking often gives mass to particles
so maybe all the superpartners are just
so heavy that we haven't observed them
yet and then in nature you could
actually be super symmetric now we were
hoping to see super practicals at the
Large Hadron Collider we didn't so
therefore is a good Bayesian your
credence that supersymmetry is correct
should go down but you know if you
didn't have hopes and dreams for the
electroweak scale and Large Hadron
Collider there's nothing to prevent you
from saying that supersymmetry is broken
at a much higher energy scale so the
fact that we haven't seen supersymmetry
at the LHC is evidence against
supersymmetry existing but it's nowhere
near definitive evidence it's very very
easy to come up with supersymmetric
theory
with the supersymmetry is hidden from us
and we'll never see it within my
lifetime anyway so we don't know about
that
but the standard model certainly does
not have supersymmetry in it anyway
you often hear you were often told that
bosons have spin of 0 1 2 dot dot some
integer and fermions have spin of 1/2
yeah I was thinking while writing again
three halfs five halfs etc okay so as I
said as I foreshadowed this is this is a
true fact but it is not the definition
of what it boson and Fermi on is bosons
pickups like to pile on top of each
other fermions take up space fermions
have the Pauli exclusion principle
bosons actually like to be are more
likely to be where other bosons are so
we want to relate we want to figure out
why this is true right why is it the
bosons or spin zero one two fermions are
spending 1/2 3 X 5 halves so I guess I
will have to tell you what the
definition of spin is well to talk a
little bit about spin now we've been
fearlessly talking about spin already
because it's one of those words you've
heard before let me pause to say
something that is really not in the
textbooks but I think is true so people
talk about spin as a version of angular
momentum okay elementary particles like
the electron or quarks or the photon or
whatever have spin and you can transform
angular momentum in the good
old-fashioned sense like an electron
moving with angular momentum around
proton in an atom to spin and vice versa
so what we call orbital angular momentum
good old angular momentum that you would
measure by something moving around is
this part of the same conserved quantity
that spin is okay so spin is definitely
unambiguously clearly a kind of angular
momentum otherwise in government it
would not be conserved so you should
think of spin as
angular momentum however people will
tell you do not think of spin as
something actually spinning do not think
of an electron as actually having a
rotation around some axis and if you say
well why not
why shouldn't I think of that they will
say well look the electron is a point
particle okay it would have to be
spinning literally infinitely fast in
order for it to have any angular
momentum at all by the formula for
angular momentum okay but it it can't be
spending infinitely fast because that
would be faster than the speed of light
that would make no sense in other words
the idea that the electron is a point
particle seems to be incompatible with
it having intrinsic spin another way of
saying it is well even if you don't
believe the electron has is a point
particle or even if you if you say well
the electron really is a wave function
not a point particle the wave function
has a sighs you know the Compton
wavelength for example and if you have
if you make a sphere a solid sphere the
Compton wavelength of the electron and
you let it rotate then you can figure
out that it would again have to be
rotating faster than the speed of light
to have the spin that the electron
really has spin one-half but neither one
of those neither one of those arguments
should be convincing to you at all
because you know that really the
electron is an excitation in a quantum
field and you might ask you know Ken
fields have angular momentum even if
they're not literally moving can the
configuration of a field have angular
momentum the answer is yes in fact
magnetic fields I'll just sitting there
all by themselves can have angular
momentum so what you really should be
asking is can be configuration of the
electron field have the angular momentum
of 1/2 that we would give to it by the
ordinary way of talking about spin so
the answer seems to be yes my colleague
at Caltech chip Stevens who I wrote a
paper with about everybody in quantum
mechanics that is completely orthogonal
to this has been working on
understanding feel spin in quantum field
theory and his understanding which seems
completely correct to me is that you can
think of spin as literally the angular
momentum of the field describing the
electron or the
quark or whatever so my slightly
heterodox opinion following what chip
has done is to say that you should think
of spin as angular momentum because it
is because there literally is something
spinning but it's the field it's not
some notion of an elementary particle
that is point like in any way okay so if
you know in other words remember neither
any nerd er oops
ah not a good day all right
she said that conserved quantities oh
sorry she said it the other way around
she says that symmetries imply conserved
quantities so for example the you one
gauge invariance of electromagnetism
implies conservation of electric charge
translation invariance in one direction
of space implies conservation of linear
momentum time translation invariance
implies conservation of energy and it is
rotational invariance that implies
conservation of angular momentum and
when you go through the details of
what's going on you can show that fields
can have transformation properties under
rotations and you sort of know this if
you just have a scalar field like the
scalar fields just a number at every
point in space under a rotation nothing
happens to it it's a number at that
point I do a rotation around that point
the field doesn't care it's just sitting
there
but if I have a vector field okay a
vector field points in a direction so if
I'm sitting at one point and I rotate my
coordinates the components of the vector
better change to compensate for the fact
that I'm changing my coordinates so when
we think about how a field changes under
rotations of the coordinates different
kinds of fields can be different and
that's a question you can ask what are
the transformation properties under
rotations of the particular field we're
looking at and the answer tells you the
spin okay so spin is the transformation
or comes from let's put it this way it's
put an arrow
that way the transformation properties
of fields under spatial rotations as you
might guess or fear or anticipate we're
not gonna go into details about this
okay but I'm telling you this is the
true thing so you can derive equations
for what the spin of different fields
are using the properties that they have
under rotations in space and you can
relate that and you can show that spin
plus orbital angular momentum is the
thing that is conserved
according to northers theorem it is the
total conserve angular momentum so let's
go through some examples they're scalars
scalar fields which I just said scalars
don't change I just said that in words
and I move my hands but let's just draw
a little picture okay so what I mean is
here is space so this is x and y and
let's focus in on the value of some
scalar field at this point right there
by okay and I undergo a rotation rotate
by anything at all it doesn't matter
what angle I do and at the end of the
day I suppose I should draw my axes
rotate it a little bit Phi is this thing
thing Phi is the same it hasn't changed
so the there's a slight inconsistency in
the labeling here but but it all works
out for reasons that we're not going to
go into we call this spin zero it
doesn't transform at all we don't we
don't pivot any spin and that is what
pops out of the mathematics as well okay
so that's one possibility
another possibility is vectors so it's a
little complicated we'd have to go into
matrices and so3 and things like that if
we wanted to tell you in all glory how
vectors change under rotations but let's
simplify our lives and look at rotations
by 360 degrees okay rotation all the way
around right you're gonna you're gonna
anticipate this is could be boring
because when you rotate by 360 degrees
nothing should happen but aha you're
going to be surprised
so vectors don't change
for a vector you're right okay for
vectors they don't change under 360
degree rotation that's 2 pi if you're a
radians person ok go I'm trying to be
user-friendly to the degrees people
under they're out there so here is again
space here's my little vector I'm going
to draw my vector pointing up and I'm
gonna rotate so this is a rotation by
360 degrees and what happens nothing at
all I mean something happens in between
but once I've done the entire rotation
by 360 I go back to exactly where I
started ok so we call this spin 1 it has
unit spin so really when I say 1 I
really mean 1 equals H bar H bar
Planck's constant which we set equal to
1
turns out dimensionally if you don't use
natural units H bar has units of spin
and a spin one particle the amount of
spin that it has is exactly equal to H
bar that's why the 2pi is there that's
why we define H bar is H over 2 pi this
is this way you get a nice formula for
the relationship between H and spin so
you can talk about spin one rather than
I don't know spin 1 over 2 pi it would
be something like that
yeah no spin 2 pi I guess yeah it's been
one is much easier to say ok there are
fields like let's say the gravitational
field ok the remember we talked about
the metric tensor field we're not going
to go into details here again but there
are fields that have the property there
exist fields that have the property that
they're invariant immediately be
consistent with why I said before they
don't change when you under when you
rotate by just 180 degrees which is just
PI radians ok so how could that be if
I'm drawing my little picture here if I
draw anything other than a dot like when
I drew my vector clearly if I rotated
that by 180 be pointing down now so what
can I do well what I can do is just draw
something that is
symmetric right so I'm drawing something
that looks like it points both up and
down and then I'm gonna rotate that by
180 degrees and if it's truly symmetric
up and down then that's gonna look
exactly the same
before and after okay and in fact that
is more sorry this is called spin too
and you can go on higher things 360
degrees for spin 180 degrees for spin to
360 degrees divided by 320 degrees for
spin 3 etc and gravitons our spin to
photons and W and Z bosons or spin 1
Higgs bosons or spin 0 so all these are
actually realized in the real world
ok and interestingly you can actually
see this behavior or sort of a
reflection of this behavior into
classical influence of these fields you
know if you compare I said spin 1
photons would be an example
electromagnetism spin 2 gravity right so
think about what happens to particles as
one of these classical waves goes by a
photon electromagnetic field goes by
electromagnetic wave or a gravitational
wave goes by well what happens is for an
en em wave electromagnetic if I imagine
that the electromagnetic wave is coming
at you or coming at me coming out of the
board okay so and here are here's a
charged particle like an electron and
here is the X and y axis and so the
particle the wave rather is moving in
the Z direction so it's coming at you
what's gonna happen
well the electron the electric field the
electric field is going to be pointing
up and then a moment later it's gonna be
pointing down if that's so this is e2 if
that's c1 so the electrons motion is up
and then down it vibrates in a vertical
direction and this we know this if you
if you know a little bit about E&M this
is the polarization of the
electromagnetic wave look if you wear
polarized sunglasses they will let
through electromagnetic waves of one
polarization but not the perpendicular
polarization so there's a relationship
between the fact that the field is
invariant under 360 degrees which means
it's either pointing up you have to go
all the way around before it's pointing
down again and the fact that when the
field oscillates a particle under the
influence of that goes up and down so
it's it's invariant under rotation by
180 degrees whereas for gravitational
waves what happens and you might think
if I have a little test mass sitting
there X Y and the gravitational wave
goes by in the Z direction well it will
also move the particle up and down
that's what a wave should do right turns
out that's not right it's a little bit
trickier than that and the reason why is
because remember the principle
equivalence when we talk about gravity
in a last video if I have a bunch of
particles I can't compare them to each
other if they all just move in the same
direction all I can do is ask how they
move relative to each other so if the
particles did move up and down in
lockstep then I wouldn't have a
gravitational wave at all that's
equivalent to nothing happening that's
equivalent to just changing my point of
view right whereas with the charged
particle I could put a charge particle
next to an uncharged part look like I
literally see it move up and down but
because of the principle of equivalence
for gravity they all move up or they all
move down so that's not really motion at
all what I can do is imagine that I have
a series of particles again these
imagine these are like test particles
floating in outer space okay so they're
not pulling or put pushing on each other
they're just floating out there a
gravitational wave goes by and what can
happen is the shape can be distorted
that is something that is measurable if
all the particles were to move in
lockstep that wouldn't be measurable but
if they change their shape with respect
to each other that is measurable so what
actually happens is this kind of
arrangement will change over time into
something that is more stretched out
like this
okay and then it will oscillate back to
this circular configuration and then it
will oscillate to being stretched out
this way so in other words the overall
effect of the gravitational wave passing
by can be thought of as forming a plus
pattern right you see the plus sign
there that is the actual pattern not the
most beautiful drawing of this pattern
okay let me draw let me do that again
you know this is gonna be on YouTube for
like a million years right I'm never
gonna take this down so I better get it
make it pretty so here's a circle yep
they're making a circle now I can make
an ellipse look at that now make another
ellipse look at that okay not the
prettiest lips as ever but still not not
bad okay move it yeah there we go
so this is supposed to represent the set
of particles moving in this plus pattern
up and down like that and there that's
one polarization of the gravitational
wave the other polarization is called
the X pattern or the x pattern where
here's a circle so this is the position
of some test particles and they vibrate
oops
and they vibrate this way into this kind
of ellipse tilted and then into this
kind of ellipse tilt to the other way
I made a square yeah without wanting to
about that design ellipse yes good can I
move it yeah there you go good enough so
this is vibrating in an X pattern there
are still polarizations two
polarizations of the gravitational wave
but look they're related to each other
by looks like just a 45-degree offset
rather than the 90-degree offset of the
two polarizations of the electromagnetic
wave so this these features all of which
is to say in a very long-winded way
these two features these features of the
classical waves and electromagnetism and
gravity are a reflection of the fact of
the underlying quantum fields our spin
one for electromagnetism
spin-2 for gravity okay there you go you
could also imagine a polarization where
a bunch of test particles under gravity
just sort of expanded and contracted
they didn't get deformed at all that
would be measurable that would
correspond to a spin zero graviton which
we don't think exists but you could
imagine you could have theories of big
scalar fields that actually would pull
particles a breathing mode for the
particles going in and out okay all
right all that see I can enthusiastic
and I get distracted from the actual
matter at hand the matter at hand is
fermions right so that was just spin
zero spin one spin too those were all
the bosons where the fermions going to
come from I mean if if a boson with spin
one already has the feature where is it
that it doesn't change it's left
invariant under 360 degrees and higher
spins are invariant under fewer and
fewer degrees then less been less than
spin one is going to be invariant under
more than 360 degrees so of course if
it's something is invariant under a
rotation by 360 will also be invariant
under rotation by 720 which is twice 360
but how in the world can something be
invariant only under a rotation by 720
without also being invariant under
rotation by 360 right so it seems that
spin 1/2 should be invariant under if we
go by the pattern you've already
established under a rotation by 720
degrees 4pi but not by a rotation under
just 360 degrees so how is that even
possible okay well so let me just state
that it is possible and it's going to
happen so let sigh of X the what we call
a spinner field spinner with an O R at
the end so this is in contrast with this
is a vector field this is a tensor field
a particular kind of tensor field the
graviton
there is something called a spinner and
this is a spinner field that has the
property that a rotation by 360 degrees
acting on Phi of X gives us minus sy of
X there's a family resemblance there
between this and fermions right but it
is different
number one the fermions statement was
about quantum wave functions not about
classical fields number two they were
interchanging two separate particles and
this is a statement about the single
classical field what is it's happening
under rotations and then of course
rotation by 720 degrees acting on sy
banks we know that had better give back
the original sy of X because it's just
two rotations by 360 all right
so how is that even possible is the
question how is it possible to have a
thing a geometric object which is
invariant under rotations by 720 but not
by 360 so we're gonna have a visual aid
we almost never have visual aids here on
the biggest ideas in the universe but
this is a special occasion so here's my
furnitures cat mug okay you can get
these yourself I think is the unemployed
philosophers guild yes unemployed
philosophers guild sells the front of
your cat mugs they come in pairs you put
hot water in them and you see whether
you have the mug where the cat is alive
or the cat is dead I was not in charge
so it's not sleeping and awake cats but
anyway you don't know it doesn't really
matter for the purposes of this
particular visual demonstration here is
the demonstration you can see this is a
famous demonstration I didn't invent it
Richard Fineman has done this very
famously and other people have done in
the demonstration is the following what
we want to do is if you just consider
the cup the mug then clearly if you
rotate it around the vertical axis by
360 degrees it comes back to the state
it was in originally okay there's
nothing we heard about that but we're
trying to challenge the idea that
everything in the universe has the
property that if you rotated by 360
degrees it comes back to the state of
sin are there things that you have to
rotate them by 720 and the answer is yes
and the thing that you have to the thing
that remains invariant under rotation by
720 degrees is not the
but the relationship between the cup and
me okay this is an abstract concept but
this is what you're paying for the
relationship between the cup and me
changes if I only rotate the cup by 360
but does not change goes back to where
it originally was if I rotate it by 720
okay
the demonstration of this is me holding
it in my hand and rotating the cup
around a vertical axis so I'm not
allowed to do this that's cheating cup
is empty don't worry but I'm not allowed
to try to hold this words visible not
allowed to tilt it so I need to keep it
vertical and I rotate it so let's see
what happens so I can rotate it without
breaking my arm keeping it vertical and
you see that is now rotated by 360
degrees but it's clearly in a different
relationship but I can keep rotating it
then it goes back to where it started
okay so you can wind the video back I
rotated it in the same sense I did not
unwind it that would have been cheating
I rotated it by 720 degrees and I got
back to where I started and it turns out
we're not going to go into the details
here it turns out this is a reflection
of the following math fact PI 1 of s 0 3
equals Z 2 see you thought that all that
work trying to understand topology was
just sort of a mathematical diversion it
was not the so3 is the group of
rotations in three dimensions PI 1 of
so3 is the set of ways that we can map a
circle that is say a continuous path
that is a closed loop into the set of
rotations and what this is saying is
that here's a rotation by you know 1
degree 2 degrees 3 degrees etc go you
can go all the way back to 360 degrees
and then keep going it again and come
back to where you started and that is a
topologically non-trivial thing you can
do so I guess the way to say it is again
this is not very clear sorry but it's
not going to be clear the point is that
what you might have thought was
topologically non-trivial thing in fact
is not do you have to go around twice to
make it topologically trivial that's
what this is saying there
our ways of doing rotations that if you
do them twice you get back to where you
started that's that's this particular
mathematical statement okay so here is a
field that is invariant there there
could exist fields that are invariant
under rotations by 720 degrees we would
call them spin 1/2 in comparison to what
we already said about spin 1 and spin to
okay and they exist in nature electrons
and quarks and so forth all have spin
1/2 we've never discovered a particle
with spin three-halves an elementary
particle you can make them by combining
you know spin one particle with a spin
1/2 particle but that's cheating a
little bit of the elementary particles
that we know of
they're either spin 0 1/2 one or two if
you count the graviton in supersymmetry
if there is a supersymmetric partner for
the graviton it will be called the
gravity no and it would have spin
three-halves but again no evidence for
that actually existing right now so let
me say a bit more about how spin works
and then we'll relate it in a triumphant
conclusion we will relate it to fermions
and bosons so the other thing I want to
say is that you can measure spin and
classic example is an electron if you
send an electron through a properly
stretched magnetic field it will be
deflected upward if the spin is spin up
and downward if the spin is spin down
that is called the stern-gerlach
experiment so when you measure spin
there's a feature of quantum mechanics
that says you're only going to get
quantized answers you're not going to
get any answer and this is this is what
was so weird about the stern-gerlach
experiment right so you have a magnetic
field let me draw the string Gerlach
experiment this is how you measure the
spin of an electron or another charge
spinning particle you can find more
details in my book something deeply
hidden about the stern-gerlach
experiment so you have a magnet which is
in homogeneous so I'm gonna draw it so
here is the North Pole the magnet and it
comes to a point and here is the South
Pole of the magnet which is sort of
roundish and then the magnetic field
does things like this so it's squished
at one end and then I send an electron
through it ok
and you might think well okay if the
electron has spin it will be deflected
so the the electron is basically a
little magnet okay because it's a
charged particle that is spinning when
you start charged of spinning you get
magnets so you're not surprised electron
is deflected and if you say it's spin
1/2 you might say well okay it'll be
either if its axis is exactly aligned
with the magnetic field would be
deflected one way if it's anti aligned
it'll be deflected the other way and if
it's somewhere in between it'll be
deflected somewhere in between but what
actually happens is it's only ever
deflected up or down never in the middle
so this is what we call spin up and this
will be called spin down and these are
the measurement outcomes for this
particular electron so the real electron
before you measure it could very well be
in a superposition of spin up and spin
down but just like Schrodinger's cat the
electron once you look at it will only
be seen to be in one state or another
spin up or spin down so that's a feature
more generally of spin that you will
only observe certain quantized answers
and the answers that you get will be
separated by spin one by one unit of
spin so these are different by one unit
of spin of angular momentum if you like
because this spin up is plus one half
the electron has spin one half this spin
down is minus one half okay so that's
more general that's true for any set of
any spinning particle you will observe
its spin to be certain quantized numbers
and the numbers you're allowed to get
are separated by units of one units of
h-bar units of the fundamental Planck
constant okay so for spin zero what you
can get you'll always get the same
answer
there'll be no deflection in the
magnetic field so well we'll draw is
just this is the spin that we're
measuring it's zero and you will always
get that so there is the thing that you
will measure compared to 0 it is 0 good
no surprise there's only one allowed
value of the spin for spin 1 sorry let's
do spin 1/2 which we're just doing up
here now this is spin 0 but you
never get that he never observed spin
0-4 has been 1/2 particle you either
observe plus 1/2 or minus 1/2 so that is
two possible values for the spin for
spin one now you can measure zero in
other words the part the the spin might
be along so I should say perpendicular
to the magnetic field and so it's not
gonna be deflected at all or could be
deflected up or down so you can measure
it up here down there you get spin zero
plus one or minus one three allowed
values for the spin okay there you go so
this is what you actually measure in an
experiment this is how spin works all
that long ring role was to say there's
something called spin it's a variety of
angular momentum it's quantized in
quantum mechanics and it's quantum
values are such that the allowed values
that you can measure come in half
integer units for any one kind of
particle the allowed values you will
ever actually see are separated by units
of one h-bar okay so good now I haven't
mentioned fermions or bosons right and a
long time I've been mentioning spin and
so I wanted to drive home the idea that
what makes you a Fermi on is whether or
not you obey the Pauli exclusion
principle
whether or not you take up space and
what makes you a particle with spin is
that there's some value the environment
and that you can measure and it's
quantized but there is a relationship
okay the spin statistics theorem it's
called you know what spin is and
remember statistics is are you a boson
or are you a Fermi on and the spin
statistic theorem is bosons have spin
zero one two double dot fermions
are half integer spin one-half
three-halves
five hands okay why is there this
theorem so this is another example of a
true fact in physics that you can prove
mathematically and this sort of
notoriously difficult to explain why
this is true you can prove it through
very dense mathematics but boiling the
essence of the proof down to something
people can understand it turns out to be
very very difficult and people have
tried and as soon as you come up with a
clever explanation someone who really
understands the proof says well here's a
counter example to your proposed
explanation so I'm not going to try to
prove it now I'm gonna try to give you
reason behind it the proof what I'll do
is what everyone else does and I will
provide you with an argument that will
make you think it's not surprising okay
so all I'm trying to do here is to make
you think that it is plausible there's a
relationship between this fact which has
to do with the interchange of two
particles and this fact which has to do
the rotations of single particles right
bosons and fermions say what happens
when you change two particles with each
other interchange spin is says what you
doing take a single particle and rotate
it there clearly in the math that we did
seems to be some resemblance there but
they're also clearly independent
concepts so how do we relate them to
each other so we have a second
demonstration look at this two different
visual aids in the same big idea video
okay so here is and this is again famous
I think this all goes all the way back
to direct but certainly wheeler talked
about this and Fineman and plenty of
other people who did this demonstration
so here is a belt okay a little strip
let me try to get it in the video need
to remember to make the video big enough
so you can see this but it's a band okay
that has two ends and these two ends
represent the positions of two identical
particles okay so now we have a two
particle system and you can see that I'm
holding them in a certain orientation so
there's no twists in the band I'm not
doing anything not nothing up my sleeve
it looks like a little bit if I hold
them like this but there's no twist in
it like that okay what I'm going to do
is not rotate either particle but I will
interchange them okay so I'm not allowed
to do this all right not gonna do that
I'm just gonna interchange the two
particles with each other
boom
and what you notice is that now there is
a twist in the band that it's a
topological fact and I could go back
into the topology of that hopefully it's
visible against my shirt Det cetera but
there is now a twist in the band that
you can see it okay and what I want to
argue is that I can undo the twist by
rotating one of the particles so this
this twist got in there when I
interchanged the two particles okay so I
did the thing that if they're fermions
connects them to each other and now I'm
saying that by taking one particle the
one in my right hand here and by
rotating it by 360 degrees I can undo
the twist so watch this I do it 180 it's
still a twist 360 degrees bang there is
now no longer a twist okay if you can
see that so what I claimed proved or at
least you know hand-wave ly argue in
favor of is that for fermions for things
that obey the rules of the belt over
here interchange the by which I mean the
effect on the quantum wave function of
interchanging two identical particles
can be undone by rotating one particle
by 360 degrees that's what the belt is
supposed to show I can undo the
topological twist I put in the belt by
rotating one of the particles not both
of them just one by 360 degrees but we
know that for fermions interchange picks
up a minus sign there for the the
fermions are going to be particles where
when you rotate one of them you better
pick up a minus sign when you rotate one
of them by 360 degrees and guess what
that is I hope I wrote this down yep I
don't know if I did write this down yes
there we go the the field which has the
property that when you rotate it by 360
degrees you pick up a minus sign is the
spinner is a spin 1/2 particle so
therefore again don't don't think about
this too hard you know
just be inspired by it don't don't lean
on it in times of trouble
therefore fermions are spinners I'll
write spin one-half and which I mean I'm
going to include three-halves I didn't
talk about spin three houses cetera but
you could do the same thing for those
that's the spin statistic theorem see
that wasn't so hard
also the completely bogus proof that is
that it's offered you but that's the
spirit of it it really is that that's
the kind of argument that goes into it
that's the ultimate reason why deep down
it is and that in turn is the reason why
I can build a table out of atoms because
atoms get their size and shape from
electrons electrons are spin 1/2
therefore they are fermions therefore
they take up space it takes too much
energy you squish them
that is why tables are solid so this
again you know just to again take things
back to previous videos there's this
pernicious idea out there that atoms are
mostly empty space that can't be true if
atoms for mostly empty space tables
would not be solid like if atoms were
really little solar systems you could
totally squish them now the reason you
can't is because atoms are not empty
space because the electrons wavefunction
defines the size of the atom and it's
not empty it has a wave function there
and it's taking up space and something
cannot squish right on top of it there
are subtleties here of course because
what I proved I didn't have anything at
all but what I what I said was the
exclusion principle that you can't have
two electrons in exactly the same
quantum state what I'm deriving what I'm
implying from that is that if you get
them close to the same quantum state
they push back in a kind of force in
fact this is well in certain contexts
this is known as Fermi pressure in some
cases it's even fermi degeneracy
pressure if you're in a neutron star or
white dwarf or something like that
but this is the pressure you get from
fermions pushing back on each other
because of the exclusion principle and
people want to say you know is it is
this a new force of nature does this
count and as I as I alluded to in a
previous video who cares
is the answer to that it's perfectly you
know that the idea that we
separate the things going on in nature
into particles and forces an antiquated
idea should have gotten rid of that you
know decades and decades ago well we
have our quantum fields obeying the
equation of motion which is ultimately
the Schrodinger equation with the
Hamiltonian for the standard model of
particle physics ok so it's a forced
like thing the Fermi pressure it is the
thing that pushes back on you when you
pushes your hand when you push your hand
on at the table but what I like is you
know it's just another example a really
nice example of how these abstract ideas
in quantum field theory filter up into
the everyday world we've sort of this is
another payoff video in the sense that
we have closed the circle it was many
videos ago we talked about the fact that
smart physicist in the year 1899 could
have thought that soon we would
understand all of nature in terms of
particles and forces acting on them we
know better now it's all just quantum
mechanics in one big wave function but
that wavefunction can be thought of as
describing fields that are either
fermions and bosons and there's a close
relationship between the fermions and
quantum field theory and the matter
particles that are 18th century
physicists would have guessed and the
bosons in quantum field theory and the
forces so the universe does ultimately
make sense if not always for the reasons
you might initially have guessed